The Joe Rogan Experience here's what
freaked me out and it didn't seem to
bother a lot of people
the blindness Administration the Biden
Administration blocked the release of
the JFK papers yeah JFK was shot in
1963. how weird is that they're like
nope people are still alive some people
that would be [ __ ] or still alive what
that tells me the government killed
there's some shady [ __ ] going on that's
what that tells me yeah that doesn't
tell me that the the mafia killed
Kennedy or the Russians killed Kenny or
the Cubans killed Kennedy that tells me
the government probably had that
[ __ ] hiding something yeah
they're hiding something 100 yeah it's
1963. that [ __ ] happened four years
before I was born it's 58 [ __ ] years
ago yeah and still gotta still hide it
not yet not yet not yet hold it yeah
wait another 25 years unbelievable it's
crazy that they could even justify that
that someone could keep historical
information that's relevant to our
understanding of how the country really
functioned in 1963 they keep that from
us because it must be relevant to how
the country still functions today it
must it must have some barrier president
being killed yeah and we can't know all
there is to know about it right what do
you know you [ __ ] yeah I don't even I
want to know that more than I want to
know about UFOs
I wonder what did your [ __ ] do yeah
what the [ __ ] did you do Alan Spector
I don't know who that is Arlen Spector
um
[ __ ] both of them he was one of the guys
that was on the Warren Commission report
I think it was his idea for the uh I
believe
see if this is right I think he's the
guy who came up with the idea for the
single bullet theory which is the
dumbest [ __ ] theory in the like your
guys shot a lot of rifles when bullets
hit bones they get [ __ ] up oh yeah
that bullet was pristine
and they found it in the gurney oh look
Magic on Connolly Governor Texas
Connolly's Gurney they found this uh
Magic Bullet that they think did all the
damage to Kennedy and to him went
through two people broke bones and it
was not mushroomed out or anything no
not even a little you never seen it I
haven't oh you're in for a treat
generally credited to him is what it
says what's that yeah generally credited
to him is what this says Carl inspector
yeah Arlen Specter is the guy he was a
creep during the Bush Administration I
remember like listening to him talk on
TV and then when I found out that he was
a part of the Warren Commission that
actually came up with the single bullet
there I was like oh so look at that
bullet
that's it exactly like as a hunter
yeah as a guy who's shot bullets when
you look at that you're like there is no
[ __ ] way and I've had arguments with
people say actually that's a that's not
a good photo if you look at it from
another angle you know you could see
that it has some Distortion I'm like
shut the [ __ ] up every bullet I've ever
seen that's been in an animal is
mushrooms that's how they perform they
mush them out they and there's a there's
a fine line between basically coming
apart where the the damage would be
dissipated or and then mushroom perfect
none of them look like this though zero
yeah there's other photos of it where it
shows that it's slightly distorted yeah
that's not even right but the re like
there there's a good somebody actually
tried to say that to me no no you should
look at it from this angle I'm like I'm
like still nothing you don't know
anything about guns you need to shut
your [ __ ] mouth because that's
something that was shot into a swimming
pool that's what happened there yeah see
that's what I did that that was looks
like well look at that they're even more
so that must be one of the bullets but
that's possible yeah that's possible but
yeah like modern but other thing we have
to think of is maybe modern technology
the bullets that we have is better than
the bullets they had back then but
either way there's no [ __ ] way here
goes every bullet shows signs of damage
uh exerting Force breaking bones damage
to the initial shooting except the Magic
Bullet yeah there's no [ __ ] way and
they had to come up here's the thing
about the this is the thing about the
theory like by the way I have lost
months of my life studying the JFK
assassination yeah I really have I've
spent so much time reading books on the
JF JFK assassination but one of the
reasons why they had to come up with
this theory that this one bullet did so
much damage is they had to account for
three gunshots and once they found out
that a bullet had hit an underpass and
it had chipped the curb Stone and
ricocheted up and hit this guy so the
guy had to be treated at the hospital
for a Ricochet from The Gunshot so they
knew that that was one bullet that did
not hit Kennedy it hit the curb stuff
too so there's two yeah and so one
bullet blows a hole through Kennedy's
head and so they had to come up with
another bullet that went through his
they went through his back and went into
Connolly through his wrist and I believe
it wound up in his thigh yeah this is
how they they think the bullet went
which is just and people say no no you
have to take into account that Kennedy
was in an elevated position
listen bullets do wacky things when they
go into animals and I I was talking to a
guy once that told me
in the war that they shot a guy in the
head and the bullet came out of his eye
going forward like a ricocheted off the
back of his skull and Ken yeah he goes
bullets do wild things when they hit
bones and Ricochet off stuff but they
don't take turns no they don't take
turns like that there's a reason why the
bullet would Ricochet inside someone's
head and then come out yeah like the
initial impact is slightly slowed down
it bounces off the back of the skull and
then comes out you probably clip the
eyebrow or something coming in but
either way they don't come out looking
like that no not after they did all that
[ __ ] and there was more damage there's
more rather fragments inside Connolly's
body more bullet fragments they found in
Colony Connolly's risks that were
missing from the bullet that it should
have immediately discounted that bullet
and said who gave you this bullet who
the [ __ ] are you yeah where'd this
bullet come from for real you're under
arrest yeah you're under arrest because
I want to know where you got this
[ __ ] bullet and like you're you're
gonna start talking why can't we see
that information yeah that's in there
yeah watch the entire episode for free
only on Spotify